5 ce match john morgan le repos il temps
de célébrer longtemps ses victoires
quelques heures à peine après avoir
obtenu la majorité qu'il souhaitait le
premier ministre veut se remettre
rapidement au travail
omniprésent durant la campagne
électorale
la gestion de la pandémie demeure la
priorité du nouveau gouvernement
si la colombie britannique n'est pas
unique john horgan reconnaît quand même
que la tâche sera lourde
en attendant que des centaines de
milliers de bulletins vont envoyer par
la poste soient comptés la défaite est
dure encaissé chez les libéraux le chef
andrew wilkinson ne concède que
partiellement les victoires même si la
majorité néo-démocrates et définitive
critiqué dans son propre parti pour sa
campagne chancelante
l'avenir du chef libéral est désormais
très incertain
une attitude qui contraste avec celle de
l'autre parti d'opposition non seulement
l'hiver ont fait élire un député de plus
mais ils ont réussi une percée
historique en dehors de l'île de
vancouver
même si sa formation a perdu la balance
du pouvoir à l'assemblée législative
seniors first ne veut continuer à se
faire entendre durant le prochain mandat
et nous allons apporter des solutions à
l'assemblée et les espérons que le mv
rak voir que la collaboration
fort d'une solide majorité jong-eun a
maintenant les coudées franches pour
gouverner la colombie britannique
mais avec la deuxième vague de la
pandémie une économie en difficulté
les attentes seront énormes envers le
premier ministre toute la pression est
maintenant sur lui ici mathieu gaye i
radio canada vancouver